[Music]
millions of people
are at risk of hunger because of the
kovid 19 pandemic
even in the u.s and europe more and more
individuals are relying on food handouts
just to get by
as the coronavirus crisis hits their
livelihoods
i have to come to these places so that
my daughters can eat it's what saves me
and while the disease doesn't
discriminate the way it
impacts disadvantaged people reveals
society's inequalities
this is dw's kovid 19 special i'm janel
dumalaon
the pandemic has erased years of
economic progress
in many countries like in spain the
country
is in its worst recession in more than
80 years
and that's weighing most heavily on its
people
seemingly endless cues for food in
madrid's working class district of
vallejkas
some people have been regulars at this
food bank at the church for years
but others are new the pandemic has
brought them here
some are too ashamed they hide from the
camera
so others speak for them
there are people here who have been
waiting to get minimum state subsidies
for
ages the people who applied for furlough
in march and still haven't been paid
hit by one of europe's worst coronavirus
outbreaks spain's economy has been left
shattered
people on low incomes migrants and
casual workers have suffered the most
luria worked as a hairdresser for the
past 17 years
that was until pandemic now she her
husband and her five children have hit
rock bottom
we were not made of money before but we
always had food
never in our lives did we imagine we'd
end up like this
luria was entitled to apply for furlough
payments but she has had to wait
too long for the money to come through
okay
please don't forget us the system is at
a standstill and our situation is very
bad
the government says it will extend the
furlough scheme
it has rolled out a basic income program
but the process of getting benefits is
highly bureaucratic
and lengthy and even with the money food
donations remain essential
demand is soaring many people are
falling through the cracks and have
little to no financial aid
the spanish food bank federation's
latest figures show just how many people
now depend on their help
in the first part of the pandemic we had
one million beneficiaries
now we're looking at one million eight
hundred and ninety thousand
yes
their warehouse on the outskirts of
madrid supplies seventy thousand kilos
of food
every day that's mainly paid for by
government and eu
aid these schemes have been extended and
a recent campaign for donations should
ensure that the warehouse doesn't run
out of stock
back at the church father gonzalo needs
more volunteers to fill the many
trolleys and reduce waiting times
they go from empty to full within
seconds before they get to the waiting
hungry
i confess that on some days during the
pandemic i thought i'd not make it home
i was walking at the speed of a person
who had aged 40 years
but that doesn't stop him one full
trolley contains food supplies for a
month
including treats that families cannot
now afford
when the children see the cocoa or
chocolates they're very happy
because i can only buy the essentials
the pandemic has hit spain's already
batted economy hard
it's unlikely it will recover quickly
enough so people
may have to rely on food handouts for
some time to come
now as we saw in the report there the
coronavirus pandemic has pushed many
around the world
into economic hardship now we want to
look at the link
between the coronavirus and social
inequality
here to help shed light on that is nico
dragano he is a professor from the
institute of medical sociology
at heinrich haines university in
dusseldorf
welcome to you now your research has
focused on how social phenomena like
poverty
affect one on a biological level what
has the coronavirus taught you about
covid19 and existing economic divides
it shows us that even
the corona pandemic has a social
inequalities
dimension when we look at the
epidemiological
data we see that
poorer people or poorer countries or
poorer
areas face a higher burden
of infections and we also performed some
studies on severity of disease and found
that poor people have a higher risk
to have a severe cause of the disease
when getting infected so
we clearly see a social gradient in the
corona pandemic
so basically we're looking at a
situation where if you're poor
you're already more at risk for the
virus and if you do get the virus you
may face
even more economic pain is there a
health policy answer to that kind of
vicious circle
so that's a hard to answer because
this is a structural problem we see
health inequalities
in nearly each disease we studied so we
see it in cardiovascular diseases
we see it in psychological diseases
it's always there and we haven't found a
proper
response yet i guess it's uh quite
important to notice that and to think
strategically
how can we handle this problem in the
acute pandemic in the situation we are
into now but we need a long-term
strategy
to reduce health inequalities in
all diseases in the long run
but given these long existing
inequalities in society
how would a strategic handling that you
speak of
how would that look like in practical
terms
so i guess at the who the world health
organization
gave us some good advices
so there's a strategy called health and
all policies
that means that the country should
implement
ideas and strategies to improve health
and all the policies
and in particular to think about health
inequalities in this context
for instance when you look at
educational policies or
tax policies where the root of the
inequalities lie you should consider
that
and you need to implement
this kind of thinking and this kind of
strategy
in all the policies which shape the
social determinants of health so there
are some ideas but we need to implement
them
can you give us any examples of
strategies that one can employ in order
to integrate the social
component in fighting the pandemic
what um seem to be promising in my
view is to focus on area and
neighborhoods
because there you can
have the participation of the people who
are
mostly affected and you can change
things for instance here in germany we
observed that during
the first wave of the pandemic many
structures
which helped poor people were closed
so they started to find new ways for
instance online counseling
or they worked with was that they opened
certain facilities only for for children
from
disadvantaged families and
i guess this focus on areas
neighborhoods and local communities
can be one chance to
react quickly in the moment
thank you very much nico dragano there
for us he is a professor from the
institute of medical sociology at
heinrich haines university in dusseldorf
thank you very much for your insights
thank you
and now we come to that part of the show
devoted to one of your sent in questions
about the coronavirus
our science correspondent derek williams
has an answer for you
after you receive a vaccination for
covid19 can you still transmit the virus
to others
the short answer to this is that we
still don't know at the moment but it's
an issue that both drug developers
and health care authorities have on
their radar
trials appear to have shown 90 percent
or higher efficacy with at least
three candidates so far that means that
after tens of thousands of test subjects
were given
either the vaccine candidate or a
placebo
nine out of ten people who later caught
cobit 19
were those who had been given the
placebo and importantly
at least with one candidate vaccinated
subjects who
who subsequently caught the disease they
only had
mild symptoms that indicates that
vaccines
can have positive effects even if they
don't prevent infection completely
and that really touches on the crux of
this question
we somehow have the idea that it's all
or nothing with vaccines i mean either
they protect you
or they don't right well wrong
it's actually better to think about it
more like a sliding scale
remember in trials around 1 in 10 people
who contracted covid19 later
had actually received the vaccine and
and they might well
have been infectious um maybe others
were
as well and that's known to how powerful
the immune response is and whether or
not it can provide
what doctors call sterilizing immunity
which is whether the body can wipe out
the virus
before it really starts to replicate um
if a vaccine
doesn't prevent the virus from
replicating but just neutralizes or
or mitigates the effects of the disease
then at least some vaccinated people
could in theory
um still spread it how many and how
often
we don't know yet but experts are
hopeful we'll have a better idea in the
next few months
[Music]